Okay, uh welcome to the DDPS seminar,
everyone. Before we introduce our
invited speaker, let's go over some
rules and logistics. First of all,
please mute yourself during the talk.
But if you have questions, you can
unmute and ask questions
or use chat room to post your question
so that we can address them in training
session at the end.
Uh second, today's DDPS seminar is open
to external audiences, so no class by
discussion is allowed here.
Uh finally, the talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our YouTube
channel. That's about it. Now, let me
briefly introduce our speaker today. I
will try to be brief. Um I mean, George
is pretty successful, so it's it can be
pretty long, but let me try.
All right. It is an honor to host Dr.
George Bollas, who is the Pratt Whitney
Endowed Chair Professor and Director in
Advanced Systems Engineering with the
Chemical and Biomolecular
uh Engineering Department at the
University of Connecticut.
Prior to joining University of
Connecticut, he was a postdoctoral
fellow at the MIT. And before he
received his
bachelor's degrees and doctoral degree
in chemical engineering from the
Aristotle University um in Greece, uh
he's inter-
his interdisciplinary research uh merges
the fields of energy technology, process
systems engineering, and model-based
system engineering.
Uh his laboratory pursues a balanced
approach to information theory for the
design, optimization, control,
operation, and maintenance of
cyber-physical systems with applications
on energy, chemical industry,
manufacturing, naval, and aerospace
industry.
Dr. Bollas, he's the recipient of
numerous awards such as NSF career
awards and many others. And he manages a
portfolio of over 7 million in in his
research group's research projects.
While his institute managed active
research funding that totals over $30
million. Dollars.
Okay, today George will talk about
physics-informed machine learning
through symbolic regression. Please
enjoy and expect wonderful talk. Now let
me
ask a couple of questions
to George
just to get to know him better and make
this seminar somewhat informal. Okay,
first question. Here it goes.
Obviously, you're passionate about
symbolic regression and scientific
machine learning in general.
When and how did you get into this field
and started to do research on on them?
George
Well, that's an excellent question. It's
a long story. I'll try to make it short.
I actually at the at the end of
this presentation, I'm presenting the
use of symbolic regression to discover
the fault cause of
heat exchanger for heat exchanger
fouling
and how it progresses with time. We were
working on fault detection and isolation
using information theory and principles
of design of experiments.
And
we're optimizing the system and the
conditions and at some point someone a
partner from
the
industry we're working with asked what
if we don't not just optimize the
conditions, what we optimize the
function that actually is used to detect
the fault. That is called differential
sensors or soft sensor and so on. And we
actually started working on symbolic
regression to create functions that
maximize the information with respect to
the fault in the system. The evidence of
a fault in the system.
Mhm.
And from there we expanded it to
fault codes and from there we expanded
it to actually discovering the physics.
Nice. Nice. Okay. Here here is a second
question. Since you are quite successful
and established now in terms of
portfolio and funding, is there any
secret for this?
Uh
good partners and entering a partnership
with uh
goals that relate to success for
everyone and uh real
excitement about the research you're
doing.
All right. Thank you for sharing the
secret. Okay, the stage is yours.
Okay, thank you very much uh Youngsu and
I'm honored to be invited to give this
webinar.
Uh I'll uh discuss physics and formal
machine learning through symbolic
regression and
some of the progress that we recently
have made on on this field.
I'll uh start by providing some context
of why we're doing this um
um and what's the role of AI in the
context of cyber-physical systems and
why we need glass box models and
interpretable models.
Uh this slide is actually from uh one of
the course that I teach and
uh there I discuss about the concept of
analogous systems models. Uh there is a
few very interesting books that uh try
to generalize modeling
as a concept across disciplines. Um the
slide shows examples of
translation mechanical system,
rotational mechanical system, electrical
system, hydraulic system, and we can
expand that to chemical systems and so
on.
And the whole point is that
pretty much the same set of differential
equations, the same structure or
functions describe any system
in the physical world. And uh you can
expand this to partial differential
equations for more advanced systems and
also uh um
expand in the spatial domain. Uh so if
we could discover these equations from
data, then we'll be discovering the real
truth, the uh
truth about systems uh from from the
data and we'll be discovering these
physical laws from data. That's really
the drive force
for in what we do. Another reason why
we're doing it is this is an example
from
a manufacturing system from precision
machining. On the left hand side is a
manufacturing system that doesn't
manufacture very well. That's why you
see the sparks and the smoke and it also
has audio. I don't know if it plays.
It makes too much noise. The left hand
side uh
process while the right hand side
process is almost perfect and
in machining and the reality is that the
left hand side has a tool that is worn,
but you don't know until you take it out
and you measure it under a microscope.
And there is a lot of thousands of
papers and lot of research on how to
actually infer the condition of the tool
in precision machining.
And
the reality is that the manufacturing
floor productivity requires more
aggressive machining that actually
deteriorates the tool even faster and
that requires an accurate digital twin.
So you're trying to infer something that
you never measure out of other types of
data and at some point we realized that
there is
valuable data in the physics that relate
to the forces, friction, and power
consumed that is changing a little bit
because of
the tool being worn, but also there is
data in audio, vibration of the machine,
and so on that
relate to physics that we never model.
And
this type of data are extremely
informative about the condition of the
tool. So the idea was how do we actually
merge models that are data driven and
physics based in
assessing either tool condition or the
state of the tool and generally speaking
creating digital twins for cyber
physical systems as in the example here.
And the answer, of course, in everything
nowadays is artificial intelligence and
AI models and data-driven models. Um
I'll just uh go over some very basic
definitions according to IBM. Artificial
intelligence describes machines that
mimic cognitive functions such as
learning and problem solving.
And some data that show that uh
um it's projected to be a $10 trillion
uh dollars market uh
um
pretty much will affect any any business
in any domain. So, for us engineers,
it's uh we are in a unique position to
guide uh AI development to accomplish
our goals, which are to optimally
control systems,
uh maintain the systems'
decision-making, design, and so on.
But uh
the problem with uh AI alone is that uh
machine learning in the
general context requires large amounts
of data.
Uh big data may not always be useful or
available for physics or engineering
purposes, especially when we design new
systems or systems that uh have uh
limited information about. Uh so, the
question is how would could we inject
physics into machine learning to learn
better models from less data? And this
is how
uh the general term physics-informed
machine learning is defined. How we
inject physics into a machine learning
model or machine learning into a
physics-based model.
And we have a potential observation
bias, inductive bias, and learning bias
that would be filtered through some form
of physics-informed machine learning to
address issues like or opportunities or
system specifics like symmetry,
conservation laws, or dynamics. Um so,
this beautiful image shows
uh created by Donald Ergerson from PNNL
shows a high-level idea of what this
looks like. On the left-hand side, we
have equations that we understand and we
derived over hundreds or thousands of
years of studying systems. On on side,
we just have data and we try to figure
out what are best ways to combine that.
To give you an example and I'll be going
over
chemical reactor examples extensively.
It's my field and
as I mentioned the presentation and the
approach is not really focused on
chemical systems but we use chemical
systems mostly because we are very
familiar and comfortable with all those.
A dynamic plug flow reactor equation
when I was teaching undergraduates in
the classroom, I would start by saying
that there is an accumulation term for
the concentration C. There is a
diffusion term that
is describes the change of concentration
because of the driving force of the
concentration differences, a convection
term that describes force convection,
forced movement of material and then a
reaction term since it's a chemical
reactor.
And
in many cases would like to
inject that knowledge into our machine
learning approach. Say it's a chemical
reactor so expect you to have
accumulation, diffusion, convection,
reaction or discover something from
which we'll identify that these terms
exist there so it must be a plug flow
reactor out of the data if I didn't know
what type of reactor it is.
It's central to communication with other
experts and stakeholders to have
interpretable or glass box models and
also it's extremely helpful in
explaining the what, the how and the why
of a system operates the way it
operates.
It becomes more and more a requirement
by federal agencies as well. So I'm
giving you just examples of the FDA that
requires that
an appropriate model should be
plausible, consistent with current
knowledge and have mathematically
identifiable parameters. That's not the
case in many of the black box data
driven models.
Or it becomes more and more of the focus
of FAA
where to approve data, approve the data
not the analytical the
and the applicant must the data are
valid. In many cases, that can be shown
through a model and you exchange
information through the model that
generates this data. And having that
model being interpretable and
explainable helps a lot with the
justification.
I'll cover very quickly some of the
common tools, modern tools for equation
discovery.
We'll try to discover equations out of
data in this presentation. In the vast
majority of this presentation,
what created a lot of noise a few years
ago and extremely successful in many
different implementations and
applications is sparse regression, a
tool a tool called Cindy.
The idea is that
we are aware of some phenomena, let's
say this XX squared, X cubed, or the
diffusion, convection, and so on in my
previous example. And but we don't know
how these are combined and how these
actually formulate the model.
So, we form a sparse regression problem
where we try to identify which terms and
with which parameters they need to be
multiplied with so that we can
discover the model, the governing
equations of a system.
And a little bit more advanced approach
and also
somewhat older is genetic programming or
genetic algorithms that uses an argument
set of variables, let's say XYZ, and a
primitive primitive set of operators,
let's say say in this example plus,
product, and cosine. And through
manipulation, combination of those, and
then mutation and crossover, it creates
trees of these expressions and
combinations of these expressions. It
follows it mimics evolution theory and
it worked for humans and animals, so in
principle, it should work for
discovering equations as well.
So, we'll be focusing on genetic
programming and symbolic regression
specifically, but there are some
interesting approaches that actually
combine neural networks with symbolic
regression.
For instance, the PIN approach, PIN
approach.
Um
For an example, in Burgers' equation,
forms a neural network that estimates
the state variables, and then that
estimate of the state variable is used
in some form of sparse regression to or
possibly even symbolic regression to
generate expressions for the derivatives
of that state variable. It takes
advantage of
automatic differentiation to
inexpensively
estimate derivatives of the state
variable, and in that sense, it avoids
the expensive step of integration of
that state variable in space or time. It
uses a normalization term to reduce
terms that are
not likely to be significant and likely
to cause errors, and finds a solution in
the form of some differential equations.
Inverse PINs
can have variable injection of domain
knowledge that goes into the library,
and
the error depends on the quality of the
surrogate, not the data, and the
normalization
chooses the most important physics, and
it can go through many passes, so
iterate through that alternate direction
of optimization scheme, and that works
also very well.
So, that one implementation of that is
deep mode that we'll discuss later in in
one of the applications that we'll show.
I'm not big fan of discussing tools, but
in computer science, you have to go over
those.
We work
originally with deep, the distributed
evolutionary algorithm in Python. That's
pretty much a scaffolding for genetic
custom genetic programs and other
evolutionary algorithms. Nowadays, we
use a little bit more PySR
that uses islands of expressions and
allows exchange of
functions and
results between these islands of
expressions. There is other tools like
deep symbolic regression and I think so
this comes from your group where there
is a sequencing
generated by because of neural networks
that go into genetic programming to to
generate functions.
I will be comparing many different
methods including what we've done and I
will be comparing based on some metrics
for the um
success of in discovery of a model.
So the one would be how responsive or
how it
a model discovered is sensitive to noise
from low to high.
When it's low when it has low
sensitivity to noise then it will be
good. It will be shown with a green
arrow.
When it's high sensitivity to noise it
will be bad. It will be
red arrow point
down pointing downwards.
Then we'll study how sensitive they are
to data data density or scarcity. Then
we'll discuss how fast it is in actually
discovering equations and then we'll
also communicate how creative it is
meaning if I didn't know what the basis
functions are if I had to discover
the functional form that goes into for
instance sparse regression how creative
is the algorithm in actually discovering
these functional forms these basis
functions.
So I'll start with
how we actually try to discover truth
ground truth from data. This is
a work by Ben Cohen a PhD candidate with
University of Connecticut
and
Ben Ben has been very creative in
actually
combining many of these tools in with a
goal to discover physics. Our focus
there is mostly to discover the ground
truth at any cost and then from there
see what
what we're doing right and what we're
doing wrong so that we can optimize the
process.
Um I'll show you a highlight and I'll go
through some of the
explanation of uh um how we came up with
this overall classification. I'm showing
you uh
several different method classes PDE
find PDE weak Cindy deep mode and
DiscoPDE is our method and I'm assessing
it here and assessing all of this here
in terms of noise and scarcity and time.
And uh
uh overall no method is perfect uh but
um
all of these methods target
simpler and smaller models compared to
deep learning and I'm citing Jan LeCun
at the top of the slides uh
claim that deep learning is dead long
live
differential programming and in essence
all these methods are applying some form
of this differential programming in the
context of discovering partial
differential equations out of data. Uh
so um the good news is many of these
methods are relatively robust to data
scarcity and
the more robust they become to data data
scarcity they become more
they have become at significant cost in
time and the question that we asked
ourselves is what can be done to improve
interpretability and discovery. So how
can we discover what we don't know and
at the same time have it interpretable
so actually understand the results. So
the challenge for us was to
automatically discover discover
governing differential equation from
noisy and scarce data. So in many cases
what I will be presenting is very simple
systems where we try to
identify a couple of differential
equations out of out of their data.
So this is DiscoPDE as we call it the
framework that we developed and I'll be
gathering it
um step by step. I'll start with as as I
move on with the slides I'll start with
an isothermal plug flow reactor example,
a differential equation that looks like
that. I already went over that. This is
accumulation term, this is the
diffusion, this is the convection, and
this is the reaction term, the square of
the concentration. Um we assume that we
know an initial condition that there is
no reaction when the
the data start being collected, and we
assume that we know the boundary
condition. So, the black box is the
actual reactor, and we don't know what
the equations are, but we know that it's
a chemical reactor, so we have reaction,
diffusion, convection, and so on, and
accumulation.
And I'll I'll go over these steps of the
of the framework that we develop step by
step by step in the next few slides.
So, what we're trying to do here is to
we'll assume that there is a system
that's dynamic, so there will be a
dynamic term on the left-hand side, and
we'll assume that we don't know what the
right-hand side of the differential
equation that the partial differential
equation is. So, that will become some S
function of the concentration and many
parameters that we need to estimate also
at the same time.
Um the way it works is by
generally speaking in
symbolic regression is one needs to
define an argument set. In our case, we
know it's a reactor, so we anticipate
diffusion, convection, reaction, and
some feedstock
that go in. Then, in the primitive set
in this particular case, we allow plus,
minus, and product.
The reason for that is
to keep the problem simple and to avoid
overfitting, and also because we are
aware that
if it's a chemical reaction system,
we wouldn't expect these terms to be
combined with the cosines or exponential
functions, and so on. We'll advance this
as we move forward
anyway.
The genetic programming hyper parameters
are provided here, and these are always
the result of tuning and experience with
a particular system. And the expression
inclusion is, as I mentioned that the
right hand side of the
time dependent for silly occasion is to
be discovered using the argument set in
the primitive set that we provided. What
we'll measure is the concentration of A
of the reactant at the outlet of the
reactor as a function of time. So this
is the concentration would be variable
across the reactor as well as at the
exit of the reactor, but we'll be having
just one sensor at the exit of the
reactor and we'll try to um
and discover the governing equation for
the entire reactor. So this is the
primitive set, the expression
combination strategy, the genetic
programming hyper parameters and the
data to be provided in the framework
that
that we're using.
Next
we will
start discovery process that in this
example we're doing deep and we
initialize population. I'm giving a
dummy example here for instance CA minus
the convection terms times the diffusion
term. This is obviously not a solution,
but let's assume it starts with
something like that. I'm giving you the
graphical representation of what this
looks like in in symbolic equation in
deep and we'll start with this initial
population and we set the initial
population size to 100. That also
depends on problem complexity and other
specifics of the problem. And then we'll
start building a model. So as soon as we
generate a tree, we will assign
parameters to all these terms and then
we'll need to estimate these parameters
values. To estimate these parameter
values in this particular problem, we'll
have to integrate. Integration is
expensive. We use Casadi and an ODE
solver in Casadi available Casadi that
comes from Sundials
and
we do integration and parameter
estimation and then we evaluate the
fitness of the result of the CA of the
solution for CA the concentration of
species A. Um using uh the Bayesian
information criterion to not overfit
uh
the data. And uh
we provide this to evolution next.
Evolution will do either crossover or
mutation or any other of the functions
that genetic algorithms use and genetic
programming uses. And I'm showing you an
example of crossover and mutation here,
but this is pretty standard and trivial
things in genetic programming. And
through evolution, it will come up with
a new model that it will build and um
uh
and eventually uh we'll do parameter
estimation and integration, evaluate the
fitness against the data that we
measure, and continue that loop until we
have uh
uh reached some minimum until we have
reached either the number of iterations
that we allow or some
uh error threshold. Uh the result the
final result is here. We gave it two
different experiments. Um this is the
measurement of the concentration at the
exit of the reactor of species A uh with
time at two different initial feed
conditions boundary conditions. And um
this is also the squared error across
the entire domain of the reactor. So
it's as a function of X as well. So it's
very very small although we only
measured the um
data at the exit of the reactor. The
reason for that is because we do the
very expensive step of integration
uh
across the reactor length and the
reactor and over time.
So that was our trivial example. And to
be 100% honest with you, that could have
been done with sparse regression as well
because practically we knew all the
terms all the terms that we should
inject in
um
uh in the basis functions.
Uh to test it further, we said let's say
as let's actually test the hypothesis
that we know it's a reactor, we know it
performs a reaction, but we don't know
the order of the reaction, and we don't
know if it's a plug flow reactor or
CSTR. But, that have a very different
governing equations. The ground truth of
plug flow reactor is what we studied
already. The ground truth for CSTR is a
mass balance equation that
is shown here. This is the right hand
side
of the differential equation with
respect to time, right?
So, we provided two data series. Again,
the exact same
feed conditions concentration for
species A, and we run it through the
framework. And in 95% of the trials, we
discovered almost the exact same
equation for the plug flow reactor. And
for an 80% of the trials, we discovered
almost the exact same equation for the
CSTR, for the continuous stirred tank
reactor.
The small differences in
the parameters are due to noise because
we
injected
noise without never smoothed out, and we
feed a little bit of the noise with it,
but it's very minor.
The elephant in the room, and I will
discuss it, I'm not going to hide it, is
that it takes about 20 minutes to
discover this one differential equation,
regardless of whether it's a CSTR or
PFR.
Then, we took it one step further.
Usually, we don't have
just one differential equation, so we
wanted to explore what it looks like
when we have, let's say, a coupled mass
and energy balances, we call it. So, we
have mass transport and energy
transport, and I can the reactor and
reaction.
And the
argument set for each one of these
partitions is presented are presented
here, as well as the primitive set. And
we evolved
uh uh
two parallel
functions
using an expression approach that
allows an expression to be evolved as a
function of only the concentration
because we know there will be a mass
balance as a function of all in the
temperature because we know there will
be an energy balance as a function of
temperature and then as a function of
concentration and temperature because
that's actually what
usually chemical reaction
depends on. The combination strategy was
that that we allowed was that the
derivative of concentration with respect
to time will be a function of S1 and S3
as defined in the expression trees and
the energy balance will be a function of
S2 S3 and we assume that we know the
kinetic constant of that reaction.
That's actually not
wild assumption. You could know the
kinetics of a reaction out of a
completely different system and still
try to discover the governing equations
of a chemical reactor.
So the two differential equations right
hand side of the differential equations
are
presented here and what we recovered was
pretty much identical to the ground
truth by evolving two functions two
different equations in parallel.
So that worked very well but
it shows that we can actually evolve
parallel several
partial differential equations in
parallel but it doesn't address a few of
the issues specifically the issues of
time, sensors, number of sensors and
scarcity and so on.
We took it one step further to study
to compare algorithms and how we do
against other common algorithms. What
I'm presenting here is deep mode and we
seen the against our framework. We have
more comparisons but this is
enough to at least convey our strengths
and our weaknesses in as much honesty as
I can.
So we seen the deals with
integrates using a weak formulation so
the integration step is extremely
inexpensive compared to ours and it also
performs partial regression which in
practice here almost
translates to
linear regression so it's extremely
fast. So what you will see here is weak
SINDy I'll start with a time.
Weak SINDy
performs really really well until it
cannot perform it can it cannot discover
anything anymore. Deep mode is about
four orders of magnitude more
computationally expensive and ours is
about five orders of magnitude more
computationally expensive. So the
elephant in the room is that once you do
symbolic regression to discover a
function that then you will integrate
over space and time you accept the fact
that that integration is very expensive.
And we address that but at this point
I'll I'll just state the obvious that we
got this result and say okay we have a
time issue like it takes it takes a long
time.
The the great news is when we
estimated the error of the parameter
estimates in this particular function to
make it apples to apples for the
comparison of very different methods
like weak SINDy, deep mode and our
method.
Weak SINDy failed after 46 sensors so
this is how many sensors we have in
space.
Deep mode failed after eight sensors
whereas in our case we could go all the
way down to two sensors and
and and one sensor and still get a model
that
is accurate in terms of the parameters
that we estimate a very good
representation of the actual truth of
the ground truth of the
governing equations. So we provide
improved discovery when data is scarce
but it's much slower than the
alternatives and that is what we try to
address next. So I'll summarize a few
more efforts
in in comparing different types of
methods.
So
first of all I would like to say that no
method dominates there's no perfect
solution right now.
Avoiding data in derivative or integral
calculations helps with noise and data
scarcity.
In many of the approaches like sparse
regression and the basic SINDy or
genetic algorithms, we use the
derivative of the data as calculated by
the data. That's extremely noisy. If the
data are noisy, then the derivative is
very, very noisy, and that doesn't help
with deriving accurate models.
The scientific discovery itself in some
of these methods is very small in the
context that if you know all the basis
functions, that's great. You practically
know your system. It's a sometimes just
a linear regression problem. But what if
you don't?
What I'm presenting here is sparse
regression, which is the original SINDy
genetic algorithms where also we use
finite difference of the data
to avoid integration. Integral
symbolic regression, that is weak SINDy
where we approximate integration
with a weak formulation. GA or
programming with ODEs solvers is our
method where we actually integrated the
data and then
pin-based symbolic regression is pretty
much the deep mode result. And I'm
showing the summarize the summary of the
performance of all these approaches as a
function of noise, sparsity, creativity,
and time. And as I mentioned, there is
no good solution, but we notice that in
everything we do, we are very robust to
noise. We can work with a very sparse
data. It's symbolic regression and
genetic programs that could be as
creative as we are allowed to be, but
it's very computationally expensive as
we discussed. So,
the question that we asked after is can
we develop tools that are better at
discovering free-form
human-interpretable differential
equation models from sparse and noisy
data and do it at a
in the context of
reducing the time that it takes for us
to discover these models. And we are
interested in time because very few
systems are governed by one equation or
two equations. And I'll show you
examples with a hundreds of equations
later on. So,
it's not going to scale well when it
takes that long for learning for
discovery of one occasion.
So I'll admit that the innovation here
was very limited. We actually
learned from PIN for physics informed
neural networks
and I'll go over what we did there and
how we started comparing methods and how
we stole some of the ideas to apply them
in a symbolic regression. That's work by
Nazia Nazia Aslam a new student in my
group working on
PINN.
Nazia is working with
Modulus a tool out of Nvidia that is one
very robust implementation of PINN. The
fundamental idea of PINN is avoid
integration at all costs, estimate the
state variable and
extensive use of automatic
differentiation
to approximate the derivatives. If the
derivative is known then we do PINN and
we constrain the solution some to some
differential equation that is
unknown. If the derivative if the
differential equation is partially
unknown for instance the terms and so on
then it's called inverse PINN and
we estimate the parameters of that
derivative using data that differential
equation using data while the
differential
equation is also used as a constraint or
in the loss function. The
Modulus has a very robust and smooth
implementation. Later on we'll be using
PyTorch another tool that does the same
and I'm pretty sure there is
many other
flavors of of the same basic idea of
PINN.
So our concept was the inverse PINNs are
designed for parameter estimation. The
loss function uses some loss function of
the data how well the data
fit plus whatever we know about the
partial differential equation in the
loss function and estimates parameters
for that partial differential equation
potentially some terms and also fits the
data. And this is done in traditional
PNN using neural network. So, the key
idea there is that automatic
differentiation is used extensively. We
can do the same with symbolic regression
actually a little bit more inexpensively
because that all the terms and functions
that are generated from symbolic
regression are smaller. So, it's a less
effort for the automatic differentiation
step.
So, we start with a simple example and
I'll go through the summary of the
results and then I'll show you also some
more details of these results. Um
So, we worked again with a PDE of an
isothermal plug flow reactor. The
equation that we try to discover is
here.
We generated 20 points or 100 points out
of that equation random points with same
points we try to
experiments we try to
discover the PDE using inverse PIN or
symbolic regression. Both employing
automatic differentiation and pretty
much the same type of
basic approach and basic principles.
5% noise was added to all the
experiments and the predicted values of
the parameters like 0.5 and 1.3 are
shown here
for inverse PINs. Of course, increasing
the number of measured points increases
the accuracy of the solution and for
symbolic regression. And as I will
actually highlight later, symbolic
regression finds smaller models with
more accurate parameter estimates.
The
the advantage and drawbacks is that the
inverse PIN with 100 points used about
8,000 parameters or 7,500 parameters and
it took
73 seconds while a symbolic regression
had only three parameters and it took
100 seconds a little bit more time but
in with 100 points it actually found the
analytical solution. There is an
analytical solution to that partial
differential equation that I will
actually
show it to you
later on.
So it actually discovered not just a
very small model, but the actual model
that corresponds to the analytical
solution to the partial differential
equation, which then is differentiated
using automatic differentiation to
satisfy
the partial differential equation that
we try to emulate. The overall evolution
of the solution is presented here. It
first been super fast finding very good
solution very early on. Symbolic
regression will go through
some steps of figuring out what you do
before it finds a solution. So it's a
little bit slower as I mentioned, but
not
not too slow anymore, mostly because
we're not doing integration, we're doing
automatic differentiation. We really
use the same ideas in a different
context.
So
in terms of time and how long it takes
to actually discover partial
differential equations using symbolic
regression
understood that
that evaluating fitness is difficult
because it includes parameter estimation
and
the integration step is very slow. So
we'd like to either find easier fitness
functions or integrate fewer times. One
of our goals is actually to explore what
we call slope integrators instead of
accurate integrators also.
But also
other
approaches to
simplify or reduce the time
computational time as such as
recognizing that there are known physics
and we don't need to rediscover those,
no relearn those and focus on what is
unknown. And I'll show you an example of
that in the next slide.
One interesting approach is when we
understand the physics well of a system
as for example in this type of
partial differential equation that's
again a dynamic plug flow reactor, then
we could actually simplify the equation
that we try to discover all the data
based on our understanding of the
equation of so that we try to discover.
So in this case what we did is we used
method of characteristics. It really
takes the concentration at the exit of a
plug flow reactor from the time domain
and it plots it in the characteristic
lines and
and then what was unknown here was the
reaction term and for that we actually
played with
complicated functions that sparse
regression could would not discover
unless we we were expecting this
particular function. So
kinetics that look like that or kinetics
that are actually functions of
temperature and concentration or just
the second order
second
power of the concentration as simple
kinetics. We used that because for that
particular case there is an analytical
solution to this partial differential
equation and wanted to see if symbolic
regression will find the analytical
solution. So in all cases the
the framework that we developed actually
discovered the kinetics that were
unknown and when the kinetics were C
squared and we were actually trying to
solve the problem using the method of
characteristics, we actually found the
analytical solution to the partial
differential equation.
So that is very beneficial because it's
not just fitting data, it's actually
discovering the a ground truth, the real
truth of the partial differential
equation using just one sensor but by
simplifying
the problem statement, how the problem
is stated by using the method of
characteristics. One could say that for
us to apply the method of
characteristics implies that we know the
form of the equation and that would be
an accurate statement but to some extent
it shows how we can actually manipulate
the data to have to get better
representations of the data for the
purpose of symbolic regression.
Then we took it
Then we wanted to study what if we know
some physics and we don't know some
physics. So, let's assume that we have a
partial differential equation that the
it looks like that d u d x plus d u d y
plus some u and then times
parameters and then plus u, but we don't
know the function of u and we have of
data for this function of u and the real
function of u here is really what I show
here, what was discovered by eventually
by symbolic regression, this
function of signs and exponents,
exponential functions of x and y. So, we
generated these data points that I'm
highlighting here with crosses and we
try to apply symbolic regression with
automatic differentiation of the
function of u that we have here.
Automatic differentiation will give me
the automatic the the derivative with
respect to x, the derivative with
respect to y, the function of u of
course, and it will fit the data. We did
this with symbolic regression and neural
network. This is the example that I was
showing you earlier with a PINN and
symbolic regression. The benefits of
symbolic regression is that we learn
analytical solution and parameter
values, better parameter estimates as
I'm showing you here compared to PINN
and a fewer parameters than the last
model that I presented earlier compared
to PINN.
And
to take it one step further,
what this did is we use automatic
differentiation to get derivatives of
solution proposed by SR, so we avoid
integration altogether. We evaluate the
partial differential equation using the
analytical derivatives when we apply
automatic differentiation this term, we
actually get the analytical derivative,
the analytical solution derivative and
then
and we find the optimal parameter values
for partial differential equation
through parameter estimation. And of
course, it applies the same principle
that solution or the loss function is
penalized includes the
partial differential equation so it
cannot be violated significantly.
We wanted to explore how this
generalizes and how this comparison
generalizes to other types of systems.
So we tried an advection system and a
Burgers equation.
This is the advection system. This is
In this particular case, what we did is
we randomly took 10 samples
out of the solution of the advection
advection equations.
10 points is randomly selected with 5%
noise added. And then we
performed 10 experiments, 10 synthetic
experiments, virtual experiments where
we selected these 10 10 points. Because
of the noise, there was some
distribution parameter estimates. So we
assume there is a a normal distribution
that fits these parameter estimates. And
what I'm presenting here is the normal
distribution and the standard
based on the mean and the standard
deviation that fit the parameter
estimates out of these 10 experiments.
And I'm just presenting here the
solution from symbolic regression and
PINN. So symbolic regression gets closer
to the real value, but what's more
interesting is that it's a much narrower
distribution for the parameter estimates
over all these 10 experiments. Uh
And the reason for that is a much
smaller model. It's a much more robust
model. It's actually closer to the
ground truth. Whereas when we did it in
the Burgers equation, it was
relatively good symbolic regression at
estimating theta two. And both models
were very inaccurate at estimating theta
one, the diffusion term.
I think the reason for that is that even
the 5% noise as it's
translated after differentiating the
function U that we estimate twice with
respect to X,
uh leads to
very inaccurate estimates of the
derivative that leads to inaccurate
estimates of the parameter.
Uh but in both cases what we saw was
that the symbolic regression was
actually closer to the ground truth of
the parameter values theta 1 and theta
2.
Most importantly, that in all cases
symbolic regression gives models with
more confidence, a smaller standard
deviation.
So, we took
that and
as I mentioned, we had started working
from fault detection and I'm going to
present very quickly some work that
relates to fault detection and how we
can actually find missing
missing missing physics in a data when
we have a very large-scale model that we
trust, but
portion of the model that we don't know.
That's work by Effie Safikou,
who's been working on on the field of
fault detection, prognostics, and
diagnostics for quite a while with me.
The idea was with an aircraft system,
heat exchanger fouls, and that heat
exchanger is responsible for
the pressurized air conditioning kit
that is responsible for the quality of
air, temperature, and pressure in the
cabin.
So, very important little system that's
actually usually sits underneath the
airplane. After I worked on this
project, I never fly on an airplane
without actually noticing where the heat
exchanger is and the quality of the air
and so on. And
let's assume that that heat exchanger
has some kind of
fouls. This is what it looks when the
heat exchanger fouls.
That is some function of time.
In In our case, we assume that the heat
exchanger fouling, this is the heat
transfer resistance, is a function of
time that is asymptotic and it looks
like that, like the blue line. And the
question is, can we discover this if we
have an accurate model for the system?
So,
And, a energy balance across a heat
exchanger. It's a dynamic system that's
actually very dynamic because the
aircraft changes altitudes and and
speeds and so on.
Uh so, the
heat exchanger has 125 differential
algebraic equations after discretization
through all the cells and so on in the
heat exchanger.
Uh it has two hot sensors
uh for the temperature at the exit of
the heat exchanger. It has uncertainty
in terms of moisture content and cold
temperature because it flies at variable
altitude. And it has one fault that is
the thermal fouling resistance that we
don't know. We're trying to discover the
function, but in our synthetic
experiments, we'll be using this
function uh asymptotic function for the
thermal fouling resistance. And we would
like to do fault prognosis. If we
estimate what the function of the
progression of the fault is, then we can
do fault prognostics and
predict when the system will fail. So,
that's a very busy slide, but I'll give
you the highlight of
what we're doing here. Um
as I mentioned, we're working on
information theory to optimize the way
we run a a diagnostic test, and we came
up with differential sensors. I'll show
you in the next slide. Soft sensors that
actually use information theory to
maximize derive a function that maximize
the information with respect to a fault.
And in this particular case is
the heat transfer resistance that heat
that expresses heat exchanger fouling.
Then we define some fault and failure
baselines that are actually these
horizontal lines that I presented
earlier.
Here.
This is really defined by the system at
the 5% fouling this heat exchanger is
fouled and needs to be changed. And at
this is corresponds to 80% fouling, it
must be changed. It
must be replaced. And
then for prognostics, we need to
discover how the fault progresses with
time. And to discover that, we need to
create some function of time that will
augment the system model that we have
already. And the system model of 125
differential equations that I discussed
earlier. So, all we're looking for is to
add one more algebraic equation to 125
differential equations and integrate the
system and validate that equation based
on the sensors that we have, either the
inferential sensor or the hard sensors
by which from which we measure
the uh temperature of the heat
exchanger. So,
and for the inferential sensor, just to
give you the highlight, is uh
uh through sensitivity analysis and
estimation theory, we used what's called
D-optimality criterion that utilizes the
Fisher information matrix. This has This
is applied over a very large system
scale model and that's why I'm
presenting these slides to show you
scalability. And it uses extensively
automatic differentiation and other
techniques to simplify how we do the
computations of calculating uh uh
D-optimality, the determinant of the
Fisher information matrix, and so on.
Uh the idea is to minimize the
covariance between parameter fault
parameters and certain parameters while
neglect the covariance between the
uncertain parameters because we're not
trying to estimate uncertainty, we're
just trying to estimate the fault and
specifically the function of the fault
later on. And the idea here is that we
have a system model. We'll use genetic
programming to estimate some function
for one of the parameters in the system
model as a function of time. We'll
integrate that system model with this
new parameter and then the in the
objective function, we'll try to
minimize the uh difference the squared
error of this inferential sensor that we
created earlier through symbolic
regression again. So, it's symbolic
regression twice. The first is using
information theory to find optimal
sensors or sensor optimal ways of sensor
fusion uh out of the data that are
recorded and the second time is to
actually create an equation inside the
model that describes the progression of
the fault. And we'll be doing that uh at
uh variable time steps. So, what I'm
showing here in green is if we stop
here, we have this information for
the fault as well as
the soft and hard sensor. And we'll be
trying to estimate the function of theta
using all the data collected up to this
point. So, I'm showing I'm going to show
you all the results very quickly. Uh so,
when we have just just a little bit of
information, and we try to evolve this
function, and we get the function that
that looks like that. It's close to
reality, but not very accurate. RUL is
the remaining useful life. That is
when I have only this information, it's
estimated to be infinite infinity when
the actual remaining useful life is
about
325 minutes. And the fault prognostics
has significant errors when that
happens. It's about 50% wrong. Then, as
I start increasing the information that
I allow, now I have a longer window from
which I collected information, I do the
same. I evolve a new function. The
function looks like that. And then the
inject that function into the system of
equations that describe the system.
Then, I integrate the system, calculate
the values of the inferential sensor,
compare it to the actual values of the
of the sensor that we collected. And
then we optimize and keep evolving that
function using symbolic regression. And
we getting closer and closer to actually
prognosing the fault correctly. So, this
is the green line is what the estimated
function would project in time. We're
almost right. And as we keep providing
more and more information, more and more
data, that is a sliding window that
keeps increasing. It's not a sliding
window. It's an increasing width
window.
Then, we have more than enough
information to actually get the real
function that is responsible for heat
exchanger fouling.
In a simpler way to present it is to
actually show to you that
uh the remaining useful life, that's
when the heat exchanger should be
changed and how we predict that. Uh it
starts uh with some deviation from the
true values, but very quickly converges
to the actual value and to zero error
pretty much
after 50 minutes and five five
iterations. So, in summary, this hybrid
approach where there is a component in
the model that's evolved through
symbolic regression, but there is a very
large-scale model that's integrated and
manipulated for predicting the remaining
useful life of a system is very very
superior to other approaches like
normal prognostic approaches that use
some form of a degradation model.
So, with that, I'll I'll conclude by
saying that our goal is to enable
discovery of physics from data and not
very rich data sets, which is very
common in engineering.
Automatic
To some extent, we can automate automate
the teaching of basic engineering
principles through the extraction of
those from data domain expert knowledge
as in the example of analogous modeling
and how we could actually explain to
students as we teach how we could derive
this
um these models from data as as long as
we have some basic understanding of the
key principles that govern that process.
Explore data-driven approaches that
provide unique new insights to process
systems.
Um how did we do? Some methods work.
Computational complexity and scalability
are the elephants in the room. We
addressed those by utilizing concepts of
automatic differentiation and other
approaches that are common in P&N.
And
hybrid approaches that use few symbolic
regression, sparse regression, P&N, etc.
might be better suited some cases as we
presented with a deep mode and P&N
approaches.
Um as I presented to you in the method
of characteristic example, sometimes the
mathematical manipulation of the
equations or the data extremely
extremely beneficial.
And what we're doing right now is
we try to further reduce and eliminate
the need for integration of ODEs and
DAEs to finalize the work that I
presented to you. And
we want to study the importance of the
accuracy of integrators when we do
integration because for all I know, we
don't need the best possible integrator
like CVODE that we use in uh
in our approach to integrate something
cheaper and inexpensive might do just as
well in discovering the equations. I
don't know the answer to that. That's an
open question. With that, I think I'm
out of time and I thank you very much
for your attention. I will be happy to
answer questions.
Thank you. Thank you so much for the
wonderful talk, George. Um that was very
nice and
many many um many many information
knowledge here. Um okay, let's have a
Q&A sessions.
Um if you have any questions, please
unmute yourself and ask your questions.
Um you don't have to,
you know, wait for me.
Maybe I can start. Um
You know, for the
for data, you know, to use data well
intentionally, you developed a symbolic
regression technique
to
to be workable for the sparse data.
As the data becomes sparse,
uh the position of the data would be
pretty important.
Um how do you determine
those locations of the
of the data? There There must There must
be some optimal locations.
Sometime That's a
That's a good question and we could do
that by
actually
exploring the optimality or some
information metric that relates to the
location also. Um
And that's relatively inexpensive
computationally because as long as
you're into the automatic
differentiation, you can calculate the
sensitivities inexpensively as well as
long as as as soon as you have
a PDE or ODE system that describes your
your system. Um
in some cases, for instance, when you
use the exit concentration, is what's
usually available. No one measures
concentrations inside the reactor
because that's practically impossible.
You usually have some some measurement
device downstream the reactor. In some
in some other cases, we applied
completely random selection of a
measurement of points of where we
measure. And we repeated this many
times. But there is an interesting point
there, and it's not too much work
actually to somehow
find the optimal
point of measurement
Right.
for
types of data that you need in addition
to as as you evolve the model.
Right, right. Okay, so in the future
maybe you can incorporate that
Yeah.
into your
your methods.
Well, I mean, I do have a some
recommendation for that there is a, you
know, point selection algorithm like a
DIM and ASOPT and etc. So, I I can
probably
um email you with those references and
we can
Oh, please do so. Actually, by the sir,
I was giving a presentation to
Kaniadakis's group in Brown
Mhm.
a few months ago, and they said you
shouldn't be using we're using almost
exclusively deep at that point. And they
said you shouldn't be using deep, you
should be using by sir because it makes
life so easier. So, now we're using
both.
Please provide feedback. We actually
take it very seriously. Okay,
complaints.
All right.
Awesome. Um
Okay. On another question from me would
be um because because of my fault, um I
missed the
I missed the point where you used the
physics
uh to divide the the symbolic
regression. So, I
in my head
Okay, you you you try to use the
symbolic regressions to find out the
physics, but somehow you use the physics
again to help the
the symbolic regressions. So, do do you
do you see the circle?
Here, which one is first then?
So, how how does
all those components are
I'm not sure
here or
So, you So, the the idea of using the
symbolic regression is you do not know
the the PDE, right? You you you try to
come, you know, find out the unknown
PDE.
For half of the talk, we don't know
anything about the PDE, but you know
something about the physics of governing
equations. Uh
If you have some partial knowledge about
the physics, you you try to use that and
then
Uh but it could be like in this example
at in the slide I'm showing here that
you know
part of the PDE, but you don't know the
function of you and you want to compare
combine that with actual data. Or it
could be as in the heat exchanger
following example where you know the
system in
insane accuracy or
Yeah.
fidelity, but
there is one component of the system
that's unknown and you try to evolve
that that component. So, we we it
depends on the problem statement, but
we've shown that it works regardless.
Got it. Got it. Okay. So, I
I
when when I look at this slide, I was
not following what this PDE plus data
means.
Plus data means the data
this function.
And yes, we uh
No, we have
It's my fault.
Yeah.
It's it's exactly
it's exactly how inverse PIN works. Like
you have the PDE, but you don't know the
parameters and you also have data. So,
you estimate the parameters and the
function
at the same time. And we were doing this
mostly because we identified that
integration is by far the most expensive
step as you could imagine
partial differential equations.
So we wanted to really test how we're
doing with symbolic regression using the
exact same principles and concepts that
PNN inverse PNN uses.
Yeah, yeah.
Well
Well I mean you also mentioned the
sparse regression technique like the
Cindy weak Cindy and also you compare
your results with a
um you know your symbolic regression
technique.
Um
as you also mentioned Lawrence Livermore
we have developed the DSO as well and we
do have some
experience of
la la
you know running those DSO algorithm. Um
the the
symbolic regression from my express
impressions it gives you
those important terms um using those
primitive operators and they they know
how to combine them which which you
cannot do with a simple you know
you know sparse regression technique
because you have to know the the terms
the as a user you have to provide them.
So I
and a lot of times when you run the
DSO I mean the tools we have developed
at Lawrence Livermore National Lab um
it does give you those those terms
exactly so
at the end you get the solution from DSO
and then apply the sparse regression to
find out you know those coefficient in
front of those those terms. That that
seems to work well
but from your work I guess
you don't need the
the sparse regression like the second
second second trial of the s-
the sparse regression.
It's every The even the you can get the
precise coefficient.
As we create
we come up with the problem statements
like really all these problems are
synthetic, right?
And
you know the solution before you start
and it's actually not fair in many
cases, but
Right, right, right.
uh problem statements, we have a degree
of freedom there to say
that much I know, that much I don't
know. I don't know. I know that it will
be a diffusion term, so I'll force it in
there, but I don't know the the reaction
term. That's the example I showed with
the method of characteristics where the
reaction term can be anything, right?
And there was nothing in the basis
functions that would
let me get there.
That would imply that this is this this
was found by symbolic regression. So, uh
there is so many different forms and
functions that could dominate or govern
a system that
you don't necessarily know.
If it's things as simple as finding the
square of C as in this case, yes, sparse
regression that I mean you can augment
the add terms more and more terms as
basis functions of sparse regression, it
will work just just as fine. But
there is so many cases that it's it's
very unknown and there is also other
cases where
I didn't present it here, but it's not
so much about finding the ground truth,
but is about finding models that uh
are explainable. You can read through
them, identify a little bit of truth,
but not exactly identical to whatever it
is the governing equation. I was
discussing earlier about the
manufacturing case, that is also the
case when you use data like
uh frequency the
um
uh
audio data in the frequency domain, then
you lose any connection to physics. What
does it mean, right? Or wavelet
transforms of the audio data and things
like that. It means nothing to humans.
Um but the frequency of those things can
as they identify and selected by
symbolic regression sometimes it means
something. It tells you a little bit and
you can at least still read the
equation. That's the beauty of
symbolic regression. But then you will
have to build models that you don't know
what they are and sparse regression
would never serve that purpose.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, that's nice thing about the the
symbolic regressions.
Um
Okay, I'm I asked too many questions. I
I do have more questions but
let's let's give audiences some chance.
Is there any questions um from audience?
You can unmute yourself and ask
question.
Well, if not I let me ask one more
Okay.
Sure.
Um
You know, the Okay, this is you know
um directly using data and then come up
with the governing equations of the data
directly, right? Um
A lot of times, you know, this in terms
of in the context of developing a
surrogate model or reduced model. So,
the goal of those those model is try to
accelerate the existing
simulations, right? Um there recently we
have developed you know, algorithm so
called the lasty latent space dynamic
dynamics identification. We do use a you
know, this symbolic regression or sparse
regression technique but in the latent
space, not not on the not in the actual
you know, physical space.
Um the reason is that um because we know
how to solve it but the problem the
motivation of those the development of
those methods was
expensive, you know, computational cost,
right? So, and and that comes from the
high-dimensionality
um after the discretization.
So, as you generate the data that you
know the data in space-time everywhere,
like very
and so we have a abundant of data, but
the thing is it's it's very high
dimensional. So, what we did was we
compress the data into the reduced space
by using linear compression or
non-linear compression, and then we
apply
this
uh symbolic regression or sparse
regression. And that tends to work
pretty well, and it was perfect to apply
those symbolic or you know, this this um
the sparse regression in the latent
space because we do not know the
underlying governing equations for the
for that latent space.
Um maybe
this method, your your symbolic
regression approach
is very useful um in that context as
well. I I guess this is just a comment
rather than the questions.
We had um
something along the lines of um
I mean, you're trying to describe model
reduction or surrogate modeling and
model optimization. Uh um
There is very interesting
uh
extensions of how you could combine
information theory
principles of identifiability and uh
uh and so on uh with uh symbolic
regression to actually find informative
models and also define optimally the
samples that you use for the for the
reduction.
An elephant in the room there is that
usually you need a large data set. So,
Yeah.
We actually had a project that took
about
3 months of Monte Carlo simulation over
a CFD model
Mhm.
uh
to just generate the data, and every
time we wanted to change the parameter
in the five fidelity model we need
another three months so it's it's quite
challenging so
it's it's very interesting it's
I think I read a little bit of of your
work and it's a very interesting
extension of
of work of
some of these models and some of these
approaches to some
That's great.
All right.
Um
Do you do you know Pat Langley at
Stanford University?
I'm not personally. I think I
Oh,
okay. So I guess you had
heard of him. I guess he's he's he's
into this this area like
physics discovery or the discovery
algorithm in general. Um
So
We had
Hod Lipson a few many years ago.
Who's the
They had Eureka back in the day they had
some really good papers and a lot of
noise on that because before it became a
company and then they stopped publishing
all together but yeah there is there is
some very interesting works in the same
field and
Right. Right. Right. All right.
Okay.
Let me stop here
and
if there is no further questions let's
let's thank our speaker
George for the wonderful talk.
And hopefully we can collaborate in the
future.
Yeah, hopefully we can.
Yeah.
Thank you very much for the invitation
and it was a pleasure.
Thank you. Thank you George.
Okay.
Have a good day.
Bye.